hey everybody thank you for being here
for this and um I'm really honored to be
here to be honest with you I say that at
all my speaking events but this case
it's got the added benefit of being true
so truth is a really important concept
and um it's I think part of the reason
we're all here is because we we have an
understanding that the media on which we
rely on for truth is not exactly
delivering the goods and is not in
incentivized to do that in the first
place so I wrote this book and published
it in
2021 sorry and
um the book was about the New York Times
the New York Times is I would say by far
the most powerful media brand in the
world it is pound-for-pound the most
powerful media brand and and over the
course of the last 100 years it has
gotten the story so wrong as to alter
the course of history in those cas cases
so just before I dive into the kind of
Whirlwind tour uh of the book I'll give
you a little bit of a history a little
story about how the book came into being
which is sort of reflective of where we
are today it's two media States and the
First Media state was when I went to
published this book I got to a very very
powerful agent book agent through some
contacts of mine and the book agent just
flat out told me no why because you
didn't want to risk offending the New
York Times of course the most powerful
tool in all of publishing is the New
York Times bestseller list and he was
not going to risk all his other clients
for some schlub from Tel Aviv at the
time so I got to know it wasn't about
the quality of the work it wasn't about
the ideas it wasn't about the facts it
wasn't about anything to do with that
fast forward 15 years I put the book in
a drawer 15 years later I went to
publish it had enough published by
myself and then I DMD apology after
hearing him on Tim Ferris one day and
the answer I get was the polar opposite
of the book agent it was hell yeah it
was this is great and I think that's
reflective of the gatekeeping that we
have in publishing and in traditional
media and the Very opposite that we have
in the New Media that is now emerging so
just to give you a little sense of what
this book is about we start with uh
chronologically this was hore that's the
Ukraine famine so this is sort of
reflection of what we're seeing today in
Russia and Ukraine where the Soviets
staling namely tried to starve uh
Ukrainian peasants into submission
killed somewhere between five and the
upper ranges about 10 million people and
the New York Times denied it the New
York Times didn't say that there was uh
not it didn't just say that there was
not a famine it denied the reporting of
other people that did say there was a
famine and we sort of know about this as
Walter Durant was the guy who was the
reporter for the New York Times in
Russia and he gots a lot of the blame
for this but it never really made sense
to me why he would say this there's
nothing going on here reporters don't
like to say nothing doing they like to
say there's a big deal here and everyone
should come check it out what actually
happened is that duranti was part of an
effort that was assisted by the New York
Times to broker American recognition of
the Soviets and when that happened as we
can see in the this this text down here
there was a big Gala event when it
finally did happen Durant actually
advised FDR to do that diplomatic
recognition he was the only person in a
room of 2,000 people to get a standing
ovation cuz everybody in that room
understood that without durti denying
this famine there was no chance the
Americans would ever recognize the
Soviet regime if it had just killed 5
million its own people for no for no no
reason no for no
purpose so we have the Nazis the New
York Times that man up there on the top
left was the New York Times bureau chief
in Berlin in the leadup enduring World
War II was a Nazi was a Nazi sympathizer
was a Nazi collaborator he published
stories and in in his bureau when they
called the Berlin Olympics the Nazi
Olympics 1936 is the greatest sporting
event of all times this was a games
where Jews were not allowed to
participate the New York
Times pretty much cooperated with the
Nazis because it got them good access it
got them top access it got them to be
number one and that's what the New York
Times really cares about Cuba we have
here Herbert Matthews was the
correspondant in Cuba and he basically
resurrected Fel Castro from the dead
Castro was all but gone irrelevant
nobody cared about the guy until this
front page story and a series of front
page stories in over the following
months pounded the notion that this was
a democratic Messiah for the Cuban
people whether or not he was actually a
democratic figure was never investigated
it was just asserted it was just told to
people until there was enough momentum
to actually have that Revolution succeed
and there we have this quote where we
have Matthew's work was more important
to to the rebels than a victory on the
battlefield that's from
chabara the atom bomb the New York Times
and this is one of these sort of it's
not a great area it's out andout
propaganda the New York Times
collaborated with the Department of War
to deny the fact that there was
radiation poisoning as a result of the
atomic bombs dropped on Japan they had
implanted they they sort of uh had their
reporter their top science reporter guy
named William Lawrence go out on loan to
the war department they got him access
to the uh Manhattan Project so you got
the most secret project military project
in the entire United States and there's
a reporter there why because he was
writing pamphlets for the war department
denying that there was such a thing as
radiation poisoning there you see with
Oppenheimer General Leslie Groves and
William Lawrence standing there checking
it
out Iraq war of course we've heard Glenn
just talking about 911 and the aftermath
for the security State well what got us
into it was the New York Times telling
the world yes Sadam Hussein had wmd and
was pursuing weapons of mass destruction
namely nuclear and they had this big
push front page stories Judy Miller was
one of the main or not the main
journalist pushing this we get these
stories like USS husin intensifies quest
for a bomb Parts Judy Miller who
reported that story never met some of
the most important sources to that story
she saw some of these people at a
distance and they kind of waved at her
and she said okay check that story is
corroborated why because the man on the
bottom left how Reigns was the head of
the New York Times at that moment and he
wanted to increase what he called the
competitive metabolism of the newspaper
meaning be number one at all costs and
the cost once again was truth and then
we have the 1619 project more recently
where the New York Times takes it upon
itself to redefine American history
framing it from one of Liberty to one of
slavery which is all very well
Everyone's entitled to their perspective
the problem with the 1619 project is
that it's based in part on historical
lies they asserted things that are not
true that their own fact Checkers told
them were not true in order to Ram this
thesis home and that is what they did
where they got children's books they got
podcasts they got a show with Oprah
coming up and again is about implanting
a narrative it's not about finding the
facts and it hasn't been for a long time
I think this is one of the things people
really don't understand about the media
today which is it's not that it evolved
to this place where it is sort of
corrupt and implanting narratives upon
people it kind of always was that and
we're just waking up to the realities of
it and that's something we can see with
uh crowning the crypto Emperor so you
know we saw we all saw the magazine
covers of Forbes and Fortune and that
made a big splash but for years for two
years up until that point that this all
Blew Up The New York Times was really
just milking this notion of s SPF as
this altruist with fuzzy hair and funny
clothes and that's what they did instead
of investigating him instead of looking
at the financials instead of asking
who's on the board of this company they
ran these kinds of stories nonstop and
that's how we got to where we were and
finally we have here the New York Times
as a dynasty and that's really why it is
it's the last American Dynasty it's a
great Dynasty it goes back 100 years and
the current publisher is named Arthur
solsberg the one before him was named
Arthur solsberg the one before him was
named Arthur solsberg and the one before
him was named Arthur solsberg and it's
like the Mr solsberg of the media Matrix
they pop out everywhere just the next
solsburg and mind you of course they're
all white men they don't like to talk
about that fact but that is true so
we're seeing a shift in media what we're
seeing is the current model where we
have the reporter at the center of the
action event reporter is it news is it
not news the reporter makes a decision
goes out to the people and I think the
next model what we'll be seeing is an
event happens there's some analysis
there's data collection people audiences
get it and then if a reporter wants to
talk about it sure why not um that's an
important shift we saw this recently
with people deconstructing the infamous
New York Times story about bit Co mining
where they kind of made a made a picture
of the mine look kind of fuzzy someone
correct showed that if you actually
corrected what they implanted on it you
get a very different picture um and
we're also seeing great stuff Richard
Chen exposing some of the SBF FTX stuff
on Twitter some of the stuff from
Community notes where Reuters reports or
misreports stuff about Tesla delivery
estimates Community notes actually
corrects some financial reporting in a
very important way and I think this is
really what it's all about is that
reality has been centralized by the
media for so long that we've lost sight
of the fact that it should not be
determined by Fiat by somebody declaring
it to be so but by consensus this is the
moment we're at this is why the network
state is such an important concept thank
you very much for being here for
listening
to